le feutre est au piano ce que le pneu
est à la voiture patrick des fougères et
garnisseur de marteau le seul en france
avec un savoir-faire très spécifique
transmis depuis 1925 un feu pour
résister 30 ans pour des particuliers et
5 ans pour des professionnels suivants
comme on joue comme un pneumatique
comment on conduit donc abandonné va le
feu tu es trop dur ou trop mou ou la
son il est mort vers la structure
inter du feutre et est morte
donc faut le regarder et tout ça ça la
main ont dégarni et ont regardé un
feutre s'adorent va dégainer un ancien
fait pour garder avec nous vos photos
comme son père avant lui patrick reprend
la sphère familiale dans les années 90
il s'installe à la verrière en 2007 avec
ses deux salariés en position de
monopole sur le marché européen il
s'exporte aussi en russie aux etats-unis
ou en australie
avec un réseau de près de 1000 clients
il ya des gens qu'on va revoir souvent
d'autres qu'on va voir une fois tous les
ans une fois tous les dix ans il ya des
nouveaux qui arrivent c'est un marché de
collectionneurs de passionnés faut
savoir que j'ai des concurrents mais qui
font dans l'industrie lourde arctique
qui créent et qui fabrique des têtes 9
pour la première monte ou la seconde
monte des pianos malherbe donc toujours
petit marché à cette petite niche mais
vu qu'on est salée certain savoir faire
on est clairement unique donc bah ça ça
fait dix quand même l'entreprise devrait
boulot c'est un regard ni soeur de
marteau de canaux pour les périodes 20
30 et aussi avant lé piano piano carré
pyatt forte et piano
des pianos très anciens grâce à leur
technicité les ateliers des fougères ont
obtenu le label d'état entreprise du
patrimoine vivant
on en reste traditionnelle dans notre
savoir faire par contre ça de choses
modernes pour pour améliorer au niveau
tant au niveau qualité ou nouveau
tension par des fautes mais faut de la
tension donc un bandana une certaine
tension ça se fait qu'en machine
donc on reçoit des le jeu partout comme
ça ça fait tout un jeu de marteau ont
des gardés à la main ou à la vapeur là
dans ce cas là c'est à la main on va
mettre tout ce jeu là qui est devant moi
sur ce porte marteau et décale avec des
séracs bien précise des gabarits alors
mais la bande là le jeu de marteau dans
son porte marteau ici et ça va descendre
ici monnaie il possède ses petits
secrets de production et forme lui même
sa main d'oeuvre
patrick serait le dernier des des
fougères à exercer cette activité
ces enfants ne s'étant pas accordé à la
voix artisanale